today we welcome to the program Melissa
Peltier who's an award-winning filmmaker
and producer of the documentary the game
is up disillusioned Trump voters tell
their stories Melissa really great
having you on I appreciate your time
thank you I'm excited to be here so you
know we we've seen and even done
interviews at Trump rallies with those
who are not disillusioned in other words
they still are Trump supporters and and
it's interesting to ask them why they
have not abandoned Donald Trump given
that of course just about every promise
he made he didn't keep he made very
clear that he only even really cares
about these folks to the extent that
they're useful to him and then he no
longer cares you know all these things
so we've heard from the people that are
that are sticking with them you did
something interesting which is you spoke
to many disillusioned Trump voters to
figure out why are they no longer uh
sort of part of the cult as as it may be
was there one coherent story about what
ultimately drove them away or was it
really different things for different
people
people who had pinpointed
um Helsinki uh with Trump and Putin as
one trigger but I mean everyone kind of
mentioned that I think all along but
everybody had a different reason because
they all had different reasons for
voting for him
oh that's interesting so in other words
the reasons whatever originally
attracted them to Trump was a factor in
what ultimately dissuaded them exactly
can you give a couple examples
well uh off the top of my head our
farmer
um Chris Gibbs he was you know he was
kind of laser focused on the
agricultural aspect of it which is you
know you have to remember that people
often vote just for their own personal
reasons not just because their blanket
they're a racist or they're whatever uh
he was really laser focused on
agriculture he liked the idea that Trump
was going to lift the Waters of the U.S
rule uh he he was just he didn't like
Trump
you know like he wasn't in love with him
but he voted for him because he didn't
like Hillary and he also felt that Trump
was really kind of anti-anti uh
government on your property kind of
thing and so he voted for him and he was
impressed with some of the things he did
in the beginning and then he began to
see what Trump's real agricultural
policy was doing and really the trade
Wars just decimated the agriculture
business and nobody knows that
except the people who were decimated
only a few of them I think with Trump
with uh like like Chris have gone away
from Trump but he was watching it very
carefully he had actually worked for the
Department of Agriculture as a a
Farmville guy and he just was disgusted
with it and then he kept hearing Trump
lie and lie and lie like saying the
China China's paying the tariffs and he
just broke it was it that was it the
tariffs thing is interesting because
it doesn't really seem that Donald Trump
has ever understood how how tariffs work
and of course he insists China pays the
tariffs but really what happens is the
United States puts a tariff on Chinese
Imports and so whoever is buying the
Chinese Imports still pays China for the
stuff but then also pays a tariff to the
United States government now there's
like macroeconomic stuff which would
indicate that over time China would
lower the prices in order to account for
the Tariff okay but that that's not but
the nuts and bolts of how the Tariff
works in your experience did
did Chris understand that all along or
did he come to know it after those
terrorists were put in place or how did
he understand that
well
she's very angry about
throwing from
TV okay but with the tariffs I think I
mean he was smart enough to know what
would happen yep and I think he didn't
know how long it might go on but when it
really really dragged on and really
started killing their business uh
because as he points out you know it was
actually farmers who negotiated those
those International agreements Farmers
had you know their buyers and they had
and they've been doing this over 30
years and basically overnight Trump
wiped away their their tried and true
markets you um speak in the film to a
Jewish woman who was a trump supporter
and then Charlottesville happened and
Trump made the fine people on both sides
comments which I am glad to admit were
slightly taken out of context and we're
a little bit different than what was the
original reporting but needless to say
it still impacted this this particular
woman
um can you talk about that a little bit
and I mean this is kind of a bigger
Trend wherein
actual American Jews are one of the most
left-wing voting blocs that there is
recently Trump has done this thing on
Truth social where he says you know the
American Jews should really shape up
here because bad things can happen you
should be more appreciative talk about
the Jewish woman you spoke to and how
her views changed I I haven't talked to
her in a little bit she's in college in
Israel but um I think that uh she was a
Brooklyn girl and she was the head of
the Brooklyn uh young Republicans in
fact she'd revived the club
um and she was extremely Republican she
was really dedicated she was very young
when she got into it but she was blowing
people away with how what she could do
and how what she knew and she hung out
with those Turning Point people and you
know all the young the young Charlie
Kirk type
Republicans and she was a really really
a true believer in Trump absolutely she
worked you know to help get him elected
she worked in Republican campaigns in
New York and
she went to rallies I mean she talks
about the rallies as being like a a very
unhealthy drug
where everybody sort of got even more in
his thrall the more the longer the rally
the longer they waited in line in fact
and so she really was all in for him and
and then she heard the Charlottesville
comment and it really upset her and
disappointed her because of family who'd
been killed in a holocaust and she was
very aware of it and she also was very
upset by Charlottesville and her parents
actually were refusenix who was escaped
from Russia
right around the time of uh perestroika
so they finally got out she her the her
mom's
dad had been a dissident so her mom was
on the watch list just because of her
dad and so it took them a long time to
get out and they had told her her whole
life she was born in the U.S
they told her her whole life that you
know this is this is what happens when
you get this kind of extremism this is
what happens this is what happens and
she started to see that happening and
then shortly after that she saw a
Helsinki and Putin and she started to
get scared and she started to realize
this guy is dangerous he's not what I
thought he was and uh I think you know
the very fine people on both sides
comment she was interviewed by a local
news station and said what what did the
Brooklyn young Republicans think of that
and she said well we were all very
disappointed and she immediately gets a
call from the head of the New York
Republican party saying why did you say
that and she said I just said we were
disappointed it's just how we felt and
he said well you can't say that we're
Republicans can't say anything bad about
Trump and that really that was another
trigger for her with her parents because
uh you know they told her how you were
what you said was controlled and what
your thought was controlled and she just
really that really got to her so it took
her a little bit of time but she finally
realized she didn't care she didn't want
this guy
the uh you mentioned the rallies and
I've covered so many of these Trump
rallies and and it is absolutely true
that the lines to get in even when there
aren't that many people the lines to get
in are still crazy because of multiple
layers of security sometimes they're
held in really rural places that aren't
actually equipped to handle the number
of people that are going all sorts of
different reasons Trump often runs you
know an hour or more late and folks are
sometimes there all day sanicans blazing
sun you know all the horrible conditions
in my mind it's who would go through
this in order to hear this guy give the
exact same speech that he gives
everywhere the feedback you got is the
long wait almost reinforced The Cult
oh yeah um there's a psychology to Long
Waits and um it's one of the reasons
sometimes artists on purpose will go out
late it it basically it makes you
believe that you know you've already
thrown in you've driven all the way
there you've gotten in line you've
gotten your tickets now you're waiting
wow this must be really important
because I'm waiting so long and it
starts to that the value in your
psychology of this event goes up
so it primes you to think wow we finally
got in this is it you know it's like
getting into a Rolling Stones concert
right and Joe Walsh's wife Helene said
it was like a big rock you know rock
music event
one of the interesting things is that
once the rally actually starts we've
seen so many times
when Trump starts rambling the crowd
will look visibly bored sometimes they
start filing out even during the speech
it's almost like it's just about Trump's
there and he starts speaking and then it
becomes almost irrelevant what he says
they've been there for the event
right right I think that's part of it
and all and also I remember reading an
article I in the post about how tailgate
parties and the people that you see at
rallies become your friends even though
they live a state away and so that there
was a whole event part of it like a
reunion of these like-minded people who
thought Trump was like the Messiah and
that was a big part of it too
um and one of the things again Helene
pointed out is that there's the same
group of people who go from rally to
Rally to Rally to Rally yes yeah you
bring in locals or whatever but but he
has a core group who come in buses and
they go to all the rallies it's like
they go to Every Grateful Dead concert
the same thing so Evangelical support
for Trump this is something that in 2016
we saw you know because there was a very
big Republican primary of which Trump
only had a very small slice to begin
with and as we all know now from the
historical record slowly but surely
different people were sort of fell off
and the the support Consolidated around
Trump the Evangelical vote was initially
very much not around Trump in the
Republican primary and when we think
about why it seems sort of obvious Trump
is a guy who was in favor of choice for
68 years and then had to come up with
the story of why he became against
abortion not a church-going guy married
divorced cheating all these different
things so it sort of made sense that he
didn't have the Evangelical support
eventually he got most of the
Evangelical support and the way we look
at it now is well they weren't going to
vote for Hillary and it's sort of like
that simple what more is there to the
eventual Evangelical support for Trump
well how I understand it is that he
promised them he would he would make
sure you know to appoint these
anti-abortion judges right any leaders
of the community but the people we talk
to really they were influenced by the
pastors a couple in um Detroit had had
pastors uh who would tell them you know
from the pulpit who to vote for and who
was evil Hillary you know evil and then
there was another uh Evangelical that we
put we profiled who is um he he's just
recently Liberty University graduate
that was going to be his first election
and he said basically at Liberty
University they did all but tell you
where to make your mark I mean they
basically
everything was pro-trump they had a
rally for him there it was uh Flyers
everywhere it was it was the whole
Community being told in essence to do
this and Evangelical Christians tend to
be very uh sort of hierarchical in terms
of
um we listened to our pastors they're
above us
and so pastors have a huge amount of
power and if they're preaching from the
pulpit to the vote for
or go to hell or or you know or the
woman who comes in is going to you know
prevent you from ever going to church
again which is one of the things they
said that you know she was going to
destroy the churches
um which is of course totally not backed
up by anything she was actually a pretty
religious person but I think you know
people hear it from their Pastor they
want to hear a simple thing yes no good
bad and that's what they heard and so
that's how they voted and they still
believe that so you told us about the
farmer who over agricultural policy
bailed on Trump you told us about the
Jewish woman who Over Charlottesville
bailed on Trump what what are some of
the other reasons people gave for you
know how did they feel betrayed by Trump
I guess
well Joe Walsh it was definitely
Helsinki and Putin but it I actually got
inspired to make this documentary by
watching Joe Walsh in in real time
change over Twitter yeah because it was
fascinating to watch him completely turn
around over about a year and a half and
uh for him it was Helsinki and that was
like his I mean as he described he was
throwing things around the room and he
was because he really felt that was
treason that was his belief but uh the
evangelicals had different reasons
um one of them was
um uh the Liberty University grad he had
lived all over the world with his
parents who were teachers
internationally they had taught in South
Korea they taught in Saudi Arabia so he
had a much more Global Perspective and
he really felt that what Trump was doing
to the refugees Beyond just what he was
doing to them it was more the way he
talked about them and the more way he
made them sound like a plague and that
really helps sent him because having
lived all over the world he's seen all
sorts of conditions and he believed that
his Christianity you know made him need
to love all those people and welcome
them and try to help them it's rather
than demonizing so that was what really
turned him around
um the other couple uh the the husband
was a machinist and he had only been a
Christian for about four years and he
went to his pastor and said you know I'm
not sure I like this guy Trump I know I
don't feel very good about him and the
Pastor said yeah but you know we need to
get we need to get the judges in and we
get some laws passed and this is the
best thing for Christianity and he just
said okay well that's what I'll do then
and he describes leaving the voting
booth just feeling dirty just feeling
wrong something was wrong he didn't know
what but he pushed it to the back of his
mind until a year or two later he's
sitting in the break room with one of
his workers and the worker he's talking
about Christianity and God to this
worker and the worker is like I just
don't see why I would want to be a
Christian if you support such a terrible
human being
and it was like a lightning bolt hit it
wow and you heard it and that you know
when people change when people leave
Cults whatever you never know what it is
it's going to be the first crack in that
in that bubble yeah but once that crack
happens if enough more information gets
through gradually that can change
people's mind and for him for uh um Ron
this guy uh this Evangelical who was in
our dock he went home and he started
looking in the scripture for himself at
this point he's been in Christian long
enough and he really knows how to study
it he goes to Bible study three times a
week and he finds all sorts of passages
that describe people like Trump being
bad right and he said nope nope nope I'm
done I'm done with this guy the film is
the game is up disillusioned Trump
voters tell their stories we've been
speaking with the filmmaker Melissa
Peltier super interesting work and I
really appreciate your time today
oh thank you for having me thanks